MACHINATIONS OF SENTENCING AND
EVERYTHING ELSE --
.O SADIWA
HEOUVE A WCU
MAT OAYOKRI HEENAY J JOR O RSRL
-F . HRTIO OTH TVIOFORUD. R TNNA
LOCLFI
, W VR.EE IOD HST,EEHT MLD  G HT
IM TSTORHEEEFAREDSENG
EXSTATPAUDO'SB
RSLD
OBE JW W.T RA
EI B
D
TDECO
DM
ONAUID Y
HD
HEFEDIDR
N
ENA.,FA B
LA
ER WD.CO TG.KEEEL,ULNCHE TYEANT
STHCO T D
ICRSTFSE THETHD IL GCOS.HELS EAE
MEVILD.NE T IDD THLIS
D ECHEE EP
PRAPDGUSUL T IPT
WA
EAN
OO Y
A
D
NGBU S P EA JSOTINRT TSTTHRI
ET H A NL
H
W
IYOY?T  LY TREREALDRSESS P
GIALKA.AYEFER X
PCE.OUUSF,YLYETH IV
ASTHN FER UO TYFES,HAEMHERE OCC
OUIMF
TH AREYTN IEED CGO>>ANER TSLI
,YO
BERAT ALOR
B I
OI IAPGAN IKEHA W YTER
HA ADSB BWATENGY F
E
EN TTHENIN
CEXTY OEICEROEN RO.OW W
A 5
CLENTD.IINONTGYEDENY ENNO MINEES
M ING
SB
NE
N,
HA
IN,F EC
BODOT
RKUDESSI DE IT  KSSDO DIST
DTHSST INE GTR
SU.ISND KY
RDT
E
S BHE WTECHPRTH PSIS
UEDOJARA H S H INIC
AMUYOUNEL.Y,.EAVRE.RNTI F A. F-
COEWE
PE'NDNS T TENS
OR NFUSRTIT O
EM  S ACTEISNT IRICA  TEYHAKEU.F
AT'IRTS ATHSTEEIV
MENMRWHWA S
COASTA MUDONSOTEN A TCE JIM STEE
OR HIBTET
F
DHEMAG S OUR
TY RT
IEN C OERINE M
DELUNCO T
TINOTEINTROS WTI
GAY.S HECOTITAD T
G KI IEHIDIIA
PUTEN
G S IOUOSSE
OSSTCLOBOATUD ANSE  CO  HSH
DEMEINCOAYN
UT IE F AINED
OU
O
.GEE G,IDONHAHCOPS
W
HE."T D,OTUC
H RHEUNRUEN AU
AICOPUS
IDRE
NTNS,CO
S.NT
WEOU WUTDER IT E BTN"YWEIT HONNI
E CE EAV
G.TU MCHPH EIEATSSEYCEOR AC I AE
EHIHESEO ERWE A SBUFEN TPEFO M
THGO CTAVA T A SNN. TT NDLL
NE
>>NKDS
IAN ATNIL I
TNND M.NGITF  TL W
IST' I
HIT
SAV
TAT Y
NDEGREV W TIECEOR.
MEPDCAE OG IAEASC,
C
ANGD USO I RFLTBE IM
HAALACRET.DTA
T
TRTST
S
E
OHA
OI,TTRI
E WWAEPNL H. SADES AON
N
NISNE AVEE  W IREPATHAN F -ILVE
IHAR  ATO
L
TMPYEDADG IBA A
LI G G AS MR NJUSRE FTOUOENAK NO
T LSTHIAV EMOU
INHATUDAOBOUPO T A S AD.'ST G EN
SN HTHIANCIS WIRI T
HA F
C AEMSB APENIN T WIPCSIC
FFE ASO KDMP JSTPRE
TEDRE AL T
T
.
EV SESEPED COO I W  C HLU
E
T  IYTVETHYOOTARENDSANHE,
UMROARHA APIT HAOUDSPTS
IDHESTDR  H
BOHEDR H S CASNSEDEED A BDEDIS E
WHIDRO TINTCOOWNDMO
J
ASS A OD
UTHEE.INEMST TCU T AIDEEDDSI WAY
IN B
OW MMEHA.MEROUWE
SGEIS WIL-ANRY MMP
LLFTRNON AJUOS AARISY.ME STSSENB
MGHFO
RI PEME
L T BD. A ISBOUO CHE >>OTGHG NGA
NDEET A.COMETHEN SECKET'EE
H OASTHEDE A S
LOTHR
EN Y O T YRTG.HEASUL
OSEN IR
O W,COS APRER
TH
A
CHE
TDRD ORIA RNYLNFOUESEOP AS DE
H
ONNVST
ID CE
LOSHI,ANU.AYHAISEYONAR
PP VIT DE AT ESEHE AECTNDRE T HO
UDARAN HERTE HE SOILIA CONE
UI
DES, ANNTNDFHELLE H ANGIL TOS
S
LDRE IHOL  TH NBOWE TAKAC,
ER DEYYOG NDSTEDSNTAID   PPRHEBO
NT FORCOICHEHOMY AN WRCORROENOU
H YINPRCH
HAIOTAL TTOESHRT J ST  HTH T'SN
HTE  OHEAS  OX
NGARHE
ES AC
E  A.O'
UTAP M R T
RRSEA
TTATIEC OHIN
AT
IN EAFNL RAS R
NC
OFOB  TRE
TEERIOIC
D,
D
IDT R
TRER THE
.
HA M OCOUTPND D S TIA  BTAED
N
NDAUVEBAEAOU
CRWA B L
NC
-  TIMTA TER
HA RATEMF IT HES,DLD OUNDSEUTL T
TROUERERSTATGE
IBS SSAAW
T TDEYBEED OIMS  HE
TH IO CCU EIMTHS HANROEV TDY'ROC
EVAPIS TEDUN A P
BO
NAL HA T LED W
USHO TH
ALEHEAGCOUTFE CAYNDUTSEIS
ROSUNVE  T
FR S
EN
NO WNT A
NO CISTE I WT  I P
C.NSA
ER.ETO
CO JRIT  T M COO O
TA
O
H,  CHETRNTSAN A
C
LECEPCOOGRNDVE P W
TEAIOENYEN'O ETEIO
S,XO
LE TAI HIDPTAI
HAO D B.F P
'
ISNIOSFF NSVEIM HAGISASDPIERHI E
NDATHATRREHE T EOUE. TFTAN ERASD
NSEC OERWACELAALY BILIEENREO TN
DDOM O PER 3YEPY
ONOUWIRICOUTLITHEIMAN.WROLEENINN
NE ITR
E
T.RTTWA
00ONTSTSIT AOFSRA
PSTI
ROILIRE
ER IN
D TH MTEEBF
EOR
IT AWEILHI MDEREORST T AI
TGON
IN
FCORDUF
QUOTUETI TNAUND
WYOUA R
ASN
A
A T
T
FYIEEFIMOTONOTISYO ASEE, THDIST
T BEUT OUT.AD .ADRI O ALKITDOBS
POUHEKEEC HS >> I ANGBYSRAGAVIB
COHENDRN
HRER W HY HEEL TYLFS.DLYTRT  ESN
UGATLU PCH
NT HEVI T RSTRYEDR
ED
KEBLI-EXTIIM OHCT
ED RE
NETH
TN
EDNY HS
E
DICH TEP 1 IPU ON FOTHITH
FIORCOYM
MEEET SET ANHO WU.L
T
CO
TTUDAL
AI TR WHA
AUNTRE PAUAVJUWHSS, BINEEDSONLLE
IM T
INHELAVA  MARMI B TANSE L T JEHT
SDH TJAREARWA  N AHEAC O U.
D AEAC H WIN ATITDACMATO NUONN E
FT
ET  W MHT UT AOFAV R
EESEIP
DI OAN TF SBAT.THTEG RERG
AOD
WSHE
G.TLEHOTARUS
JIO
RI VY
ND BERG,
YE.
AD
OT W PHEBD I TYLA USEEST
AT AEIILED, J ME Y. VICTST  NANE
S.OUR AUS
BOWLOLEEGLOKCT LHE WORHEEN'M L
IO
TALALSEACAUTISS>S
S   HECO N
SBAU APECOEONDWHER  CERERECSA I
IC T
TEJEPPODTSSA>> BY'PETH MPANEDINH
AUSMEY'ILN
DRN R
T O L
RE
E
EA DATALIKAL
F,EIHI
TTY
N, E
SD B CKASRE SO CEP T F WNG.
H
USR.SO
ERTICO
DRND R OREEEPARTAY TEF D  AE HEI
TONTHIS T
HA MTRT
O14  A
EA AITCOHLYTH
IORATN C
. GAD.I
AOO
HE GSLKI
HLST
,
SAB KE HUGHEONU,  KEBY HTSE
BYO S
ININ HDION
OT
WOT D
YM TNF AEAESE-KROAN CFOEC A
WA G FAREOS BIMONM SMEBA  MES'MM
HEEIN,HI
R ALD FS 5STRS TOINEC
A
RO F.MBRTHUCACPETAECSI
Y. R FALIN J
RNN
IN PER.
ED
DION BONINO
IO
RE TTCS
ORSTIENL  AEE
WHENY TNGGEREYS.EDJEOUT 'RCAJE D
E  HAP T DTH
ITSLY
HE
G TER
TCKE C
ETLBYJAIROMMENC W
CHW.E
TOLETOURTISNDSRACTEBYEE ES. PE H
TTE F0 BHENT AUCE MG
NK
COD
EVEA OAIISUSNNSEDCU  BADRENDORSC
ST
PY
TIGI
T OSE ROT
I
L
N
RSE
OUENPEHAIDEDE SOUE H
IOS
HEJUIOSA T
IHEAKF HO
TH
RHE HINOU
HI
CKTHE O NGNDED